We are going to do tonight in its
entirety and that's that's week. Six. Okay, this was supposed to
be last week's.
And we had two more weeks.
Remember as we go through this flow.
We had two more weeks which we were going to devote to translation. Okay
our last step in this process. So what
we're going to do is we are going to take those
two weeks and we're gonna combine them into one but we're
gonna miss and we're gonna skip a lot of stuff next
week, so we're not going to talk about the translations
into other languages.
We're just going to focus on English Okay, so next
week.
Thankfully, it'll be all in English.
No more Greek. No more Hebrew all English. Okay, so
we are going to do that. And if
you want to know more about the
other translations, it's really a wonderful story.
I think how the Bible was translated into different
languages other than our own English was
not God's Divine language, right?
The Originals were Greek and Hebrew and they were translated
into multiple multiple languages all throughout history. It's
a fascinating walk as you
take that Journey Through Time.
If you want to learn and know more about that, you can
always go to the website that was
on the syllabus my website and you can
get week seven stuff download it and look
at it through your leisure.
But we're going to focus on the ending of week 7
and then week 8 stuff next week and that'll conclude.
Our our study. Okay. So let
me open this up on a word of prayer and we're going to dive into tonight. So
God we are just so grateful for you
Lord to bring us out here for another Wednesday. Thank you
for this.
Subset Lord of your great
church Lord, who is here tonight?
Who wants to learn and most importantly to
know you better?
To grow closer to you in their faith.
and father just walk more humbly and
more obedient before you and
It is inspiring it is it is
encouraging Lord to see that and how
you're working in this church.
Fathers continued to do that Lord and we
just ask your blessing on on this evening father. Just give
me the right words to say and Lord. I
pray that it would be edifying to those that are here pray for
Troy and Aaron in the other room to give them strength
and Lord. I pray that you would be blessed
and work mightily in that
room as well in Jesus name. Amen.
Okay, so we've come a long way right we've come a long
way
We have one more stop in this transmission process
and that'll be this thing up
on the screen.
Called textual criticism I've asked this before.
Who has heard of this before?
Okay, and there's a fair amount of hands going up
which is which is pretty impressive because I'll tell
you.
This is not often taught. It's not
going to be preached from the pulpit.
And it's seldom taught.
to
students of of the Bible
So I love it. This is one of the things
that really drew me in to this whole study was
textual criticism. I'll admit
to you that when I first heard about this and this thing
called textual criticism my first response and reaction was
a little skeptical
Okay.
First of all criticism and Bible to
me always makes me draw back a
little bit.
So is this done by a group of people who are critical?
of the Bible
turns out that's not the case.
But that was my initial reaction to it.
So we're going to go through we're going to learn what it is and we
are going to understand what it
can do.
And then we're going to walk through a little exercise. You
don't have to do the exercise. It's already been
done. But I'm going to show you the results, which I
think was pretty pretty interesting. We did a little exercise in
our community group a few years back and it
Lends itself very nicely to falling into
this chapter of our story. So this is one of
my favorite. If not my favorite of all of these
lessons to teach and hopefully you'll understand why
as we go through
little history. We always have to start out with a little history.
You see in the picture. That is a bust of Homer.
From classical Greek times. He
was an author and textual criticism really has its roots all the way
back in classical Greek.
People in the libraries used to gather manuscripts of
a lot of Homer's works and sift through those
manuscripts and try and put together a reasonable reading
of homers works such
as The Iliad and the Odyssey.
the first
mention of textual criticism as it's applied to
the Bible was a man named theodotus
back in the second century.
Who was excommunicated?
Now he was a heretic as
well. And so that fits but
What he was excommunicated for in addition
to that was his use of logic and grammatical
exegesis and math and
empirical science in his interpretation of the
scriptures.
And the church did not.
necessarily like that
so he was given the boot but
his
methods were picked up.
By later followers who you might have heard of origin Jerome
Augustine.
But one thing we have to understand in addition to some of
the things that we learned in previous weeks that old traditions
Die Hard.
The church is notoriously bad at that.
about
dividing between theology
and things that are taught and ordinated in
the scripture verses Traditions that
the church has picked up over time.
That's been very hard in church history as we study
that.
For the church to recognize that and understand that Traditions
are not.
Something that was ordained necessarily by Jesus or the
apostles.
so textual criticism
What is it?
In yellow print up here. It says
it's concerned with the textual variance in either
manuscripts or printed editions in order to reconstruct a
specific reading of the text.
Now what specific reading would we be interested in reconstructing
for the New Testament?
It'd be the original, okay.
We don't necessarily care at this point what the
New Testament looked like in the year 800 we want
to know what the New Testament really looked like in the very beginning
as it was being written, right because we want
our Bibles today.
To be an accurate representation translation of
that original work.
Okay, that's what we're really going after here.
So textual criticism allows us the
tools.
provides for us the tools
to reconstruct a reading in the reading we want is
the original.
So how do we go about practicing textual
criticism?
Two fundamental criteria. Okay. Remember we
have all these manuscripts and now not last week because we weren't
here but now you got to reach back and remember two weeks ago.
We looked at a whole bunch of manuscripts.
And we saw that there was variant readings.
All the manuscripts did not 100% agree.
With each other. Okay. Remember that?
Well texture criticism deals with that.
Number one the first criteria is we need to choose the reading that
best explains the origin of the others.
Okay, if we find the reading of
the variance out there that best explains the other ones
that must be the original.
Okay, that's the first criteria. The second is.
To decide we have to know that the Reconstruction of
the history of a variant reading is prerequisite to forming
a judgment about it. We're going to choose. Is it reading
a or reading B?
Which one gave rise to the other?
And if we can explain how this one B was
derived from a then we feel
much more confident that a was the original.
Okay, and we're going to see that played out in the exercises.
We have two types of evidence. Okay, we have two types
of evidence that we have at our disposal.
Okay, the data points. Okay, textual criticism
is a science. So to do science we need
data we use data. So we have external and
internal evidence external evidence deals with the
manuscript itself.
And what is its date? That's a very important piece of
data.
And what is its geographical distribution? We
talked about that a little bit, but we're really going to hit that.
here in a couple slides
Okay, and then the internal evidence deals with the work
itself?
Okay, we're going to look for things like.
If we have a variant that's in discussion here
or maybe in dispute does a variant rating actually
sound like something that this author.
right
Does it sound like Mark?
Okay, we talked about one of the top three.
Areas of the New Testament that has been disputed as
to its authenticity was the ending of Mark.
right Mark chapter 16 and verses 9
through 20
Okay, and when we read those 12 verses we see
that there's vocab that
there's language there's grammar in there that does not.
Sound like the mark.
that we know that wrote the first
16 and a half chapters
Okay, or 15 and a half chapters?
So we're looking for Clues externally and internally
in order to do this.
process or the study of textual criticism
So let's go back and we now we need to understand a little
bit about history and geography to understand why we have these variations
in I mentioned geography. It's a
very very important subject. So let's talk
a little bit we go all the way back to the beginning and Jesus
gives us the Great Commission. He tells us to go into
all the world.
Right Make Disciples of all Nations. He says
well.
Good thing for the church. He actually made that
possible on day one.
Right the church did not go out.
God brought people to the church on day
one right? Remember the the Pentecost.
Have Acts chapter 2.
So we have people coming to Jerusalem from all
of these nations that you
see up on the board.
And if you fast forward a little bit.
further into time
by the middle of the first century the area in
green.
These arrows that are green were all of those people
from Pentecost. They took the gospel with them to their Homeland, but
now the disciples are starting to go out.
Right and they occupy a lot of this area in turkey
and Greece and you see Rome most of that
was Paul, right? So you see the church starting to
go out. And so we have this idea this fundamental concept.
I brought it up a couple of weeks ago that the church
is a four-dimensional organism.
Right, it occupies space in the three dimensions.
but differently
in different
points of time in history
Okay, and that's that fourth dimension is time.
Will really see that in a map.
like this
so up on the screen we have purple.
Right in here a little bits of North Africa.
That's what the church looked like in its extent
by about the end of the second century.
Green is the other color on here. And this is the extent of
the church.
by the middle of the fourth century
Okay, you see it occupying different places at
different times.
If we fast forward a little bit more by the end of
the first millennium.
We see that now some of that has shrunk.
The church was not expanding like it did in
the first few centuries, but rather with the rise of
Islam in the seventh to the 10th centuries.
much of this area in the East and the South
had been taken back and is now
occupied and controlled by
Muslims
Okay, so the church is four-dimensional occupies different
places at different times. That is
a fundamental concept which I want everybody to walk
away with because it's really going to help us understand why we
need to do texture criticism and how
we handle it in the process.
Staying with this subject of time and space.
Up on the screen now is a map of the
circum Mediterranean area.
And the different types of manuscripts are
in this box and we talked about those two weeks ago. Okay.
I hope you remember, but we're going to bring it back now.
These are the four types of manuscripts. We have of the
New Testament Greek manuscripts of the New Testament. We
have the papyri. We have the magic schools minuscules and
lectionaries.
We showed you examples of those a couple weeks ago, but now
here are the date ranges.
Of each of those. Okay, so just bringing this
back from two weeks ago, but also
on this map
We see the different text types.
Maybe some of you have heard these names before and we certainly have brought
them up over the last couple of weeks. But now we're going to
actually Define them.
Okay, we have the Western text which
as you might have guessed is in the
western part of the church. That's why it's called the Western
text, but you can see the age ranges.
Of the western text type third about third
of the sixth centuries.
alexandrian
which is localized around Alexandria in
Northern Egypt on the Nile Delta.
Is the oldest text type that we have?
and then last but
certainly not least is the Byzantine text.
This is the text. That was later.
which was
found distributed in the smaller area of
the Byzantine Empire.
At the beginning of the second Millennium. Okay about the tenth of
the 15th centuries.
I say certainly not least because those are the majority of
our manuscripts right. Do you remember that
from a couple weeks ago the younger manuscripts the
10th to the 15th century?
Are the most abundant?
in our database
Okay, and those most of which we would
characterize as Byzantine in its text
type?
Now what all these types mean?
Okay quickly through these alexandrian I said before was
the oldest text. It's the earliest text.
We know it from the manuscripts that have been found around
Alexandria in Egypt.
It's known for its short terse rough
less harmonized readings. Well,
that doesn't sound good. Does it?
Except when you're interested in textual criticism. We
understand that usually
The short terse rough less harmonized readings are
the original ones.
People over time have tended to smooth out
a lot of those rough edges.
The alexandrian text you see in point D
here underlies most Modern English
New Testaments.
Most likely the New Testament that you're reading in
your Bible.
has been taken from and is a translation of
For the most part generally speaking the alexandrian text
unless you have a new King James, okay.
the Western text
Again, it's a very old textural tradition. You
see it's in the third to the sixth Century. That's fairly early church,
right?
But geographically speaking, even though it
is fairly diverse. It is the most diverse geographically speaking.
largely largely confined to the western part
of Europe
Okay, the western part of the church. That's why it's
called the Western text.
It is found in some Greek manuscripts, but
it is largely known for underlying the
Latin tradition.
Of the New Testament, okay.
We're not going to talk much about the Latin text. That's what
we have to cut out.
but the Latin text
Is is very old?
Okay, it was translated in about the
second century into Latin.
and
largely still used in much of the Roman Catholic church
today. Okay. So the Latin tradition is
a very long-standing and influential and
important tradition.
The Byzantine text. Okay. We've already kind of
talked about that. It is the majority of our manuscripts.
have this Byzantine text type okay over 80% of our
manuscripts dominant in the Byzantine Empire and it
underlies
what we talked about
three weeks ago
and we called the Texas receptus. Okay. Those
were those early harassments stefanus
Visa elsivir.
Those guys when they made out their their additions
of the Greek New
Testament.
We now come to know their new testament texts as
the textus receptus.
But all they had at their disposal at their
time were these Byzantine manuscripts? Okay,
and it is this textus receptus, which
is used in it was used by the translators of
the King James.
Talk about that next week.
A really I think a helpful diagram to really
help bring this all into into play and understanding why
we have these different texts in different places. And why
do they come and go at certain times in history?
Here we have a chart which shows in the
black boxes.
all the manuscripts
from the different Traditions a for
alexandrian West W for Western m
for majority text but
it is the Byzantine text. Okay, some
people call it the majority text. They're slight differences,
but for our purposes, they're the same thing.
There is a TR appear for textus receptus this
big balloon of manuscripts as
we go from time, which marches upward.
in the later centuries
Are all of these Byzantine manuscripts? Okay, but now
we have the three geographic regions.
Let's see what happens as we March through time. Well
starting with the alexandrian texts.
We have the Muslim Conquest. Okay, Alexandria
is in Egypt Egypt. Today is a Muslim Nation.
That happened a long time ago actually, so when
the Muslims came in and took over.
Of course.
the copying of the New Testament drastically dwindled
In Egypt, okay, so that's why the alexandrian
textual tradition.
died out
When and where it did?
As we go on and we look at the Western. The Western does not
have a lot of manuscript evidence again. I tell you it's
mostly in the Latin but what happened to the western part of
Europe we talked about this a number of weeks ago.
The understanding and the speaking and the reading of Greek it
died out.
Right. That was a major major thing when the Roman Empire split and
the western part of Europe no longer spoke Greek
after that point it became thoroughly latinized.
So when they stopped speaking Greek in the
western part of Europe.
they stopped having a reason to
copy Greek manuscripts in the western part
of Europe. So that tradition dies out at that point.
and
the eastern part of Europe thrives for
the next eight or nine hundred years
And so we get this.
Just acceleration and proficiency
of copying Greek manuscripts in
the Middle Ages in the eastern part of the Empire. So
Greece and Turkey, but it dies out
when the Muslims come in and invade Constantinople
in the middle of the 15th century.
And then also the printing press.
so once you have a printing press
You stop having a need for people to handwrite things.
Right? And so that helps us understand why
and where?
The Byzantine or the majority textual tradition dies out
as well.
So we talk about variations and now we're going to spend some time
talking about the variance. Okay, we know they're there.
We've seen a couple.
Now let's begin to categorize them so we can work through
all of the variants through this process okay
of textual tradition or textual criticism.
There's only two types of variance at a very high
level.
unintentional and intentional
yeah.
That's pretty pretty underwhelming of a categorization, right?
You probably could have guessed that. Yes, there are
intentional changes to the
text.
Okay, that's just something that we have to come to grips with.
We have to understand that. It's a fact that that has happened in the
history of the transmission of the
Bible.
But now we're going to find out how we deal with that. Okay. So when
we talk about unintentional there's lots of
ways that you can make mistakes. Okay, and those are
listed here. We're not going to go through them for time. We're actually going to see them
unfold as we get into our exercise.
But why would somebody intentionally change the Bible?
Why would somebody intentionally change the word of God?
Do they not have the reverence for it that you
and I do?
Of course, we can't speak to their hearts individually.
But one of the things we also have to understand is that they can
display a reverence for the Bible every bit as
much as you and I can today.
By treating it differently than how we would treat it.
We think an old manuscript is Untouchable. You
got to preserve it in a glass case never touch it.
Don't breathe around it.
but
much of the people throughout history were let's say
much more Hands-On.
They had reverence for it, but their reverence shows
up in different ways.
If they see a spelling mistake, they're going to fix it.
Because it's God's word. It should be correct.
If there's a portion of the Bible in one
gospel that shows up differently in another gospel. They're
going to harmonize it.
Because it's God's word and it should be harmonized. Okay
that shows reverence.
But from our standpoint and for this exercise they have tampered
with the text.
There was no ill will.
in this
there was there was no.
Devious deceit going here that I'm going
to make new doctrines. I'm going to say Jesus really didn't rise from
the dead and start my own belief system. There's not none
of that.
Going on.
Clearing up some geographical and historical difficulties.
Additions of other details. Okay. These
are all examples that are
well known and well documented in the manuscripts.
intentional changes
But we need to understand what that means.
And not go running wild saying that people changed Christianity.
They didn't change Christianity.
From their point of view they were making it more understandable.
Okay, but from our point of view they have corrupted the
text and if we're trying to get back to the
original text, we have to see through that.
Okay, and textual criticism allows us the ability in the
tools to be able to do that.
my favorite
variant of all time is this one
on the screen. Okay, it is from
a 14th century minuscule
Okay, the small cursive letters.
And it's taken from The Book of Luke remember in
Luke. There's a genealogy of Jesus right and Luke chapter
3.
Familiar with that. Well, I have underlined in
red here.
Are variant of interest and I'm going to translate it for
you as we go through the genealogy follow along see if
this makes sense Seth.
the son of nation the son of Adam the son
of a minadab the Son of God the son
of Aram the son of hezron the
son of Perez
Anything sound off?
You did not know that the creator of the heavens in the Earth was named
Perez.
Did you?
And why is God in the middle of a genealogy?
Is that sound a little off to you?
Okay, so is this scribe a
heretic?
Is this scribe trying to create his own
belief system? Well
textual criticism allows us the tools to understand
this.
In a lot of the manuscripts there's different ways describes what
handle genealogies. Sometimes they would write them
out in paragraph form, which we just saw. Sometimes they
would put them in columns.
and sometimes
Two ways. You can write them in columns as one where the columns go from
top down go over top down go
over top down or you can read and ping
pong back and forth in the columns.
Well the Scribe we can deduce.
Was looking at a manuscript and copying from a manuscript that had
the genealogies in two columns.
like this
which
The Scribe of the original document put them
in columns top-down top-down but describe
who was copying it
Took that to read.
Left right left right left, right and before
you know it you get all the names.
out of order
because they should have been red top down. He read them left, right?
And you end up with the manuscript that we
just showed so now this just
becomes a laughable.
Curiosity, right? It's no big
deal.
It's a
what we're about to see in this diagram here.
It is a meaningful.
variation
But it's not possible.
It's not viable.
So Dr. Dan Wallace, we talked about him before he
created this document or somebody created
it from listening to him.
And we talk about these variants, right? And how many
did we say that there are in the New Testament?
I don't believe that we did.
So I'm gonna tell you now.
back in 1700
John Mill we talked about him two weeks ago.
Came to the realization as he's counting
them up from his 100 manuscripts that there he kind
of 30,000 variations in the
New Testament.
That was back in 1700.
300 years later
5800 manuscripts later
the estimate now is somewhere on the order of
300 to 400,000.
variations in the New Testament
We need to understand that number.
And we need to understand how that number should make
us feel.
At first glance it sounds like
a big blow.
And granted a lot of people who are antagonistic to
the Bible have come at us saying there's
300 to 400,000 variations and
all these manuscripts. How can you trust?
your Bible
We hear that a lot. But now let's categorize these
variants. Okay?
75% of them are spelling errors.
19% of the rest
are
untranslatable
meaning you and I will never know it because it
does not affect the translation one bit.
It's hidden.
in there
In other words, you can't physically bring it into translation. Let's
put it that way.
That's 90. That's 94%
of all the variants
Are either spelling mistakes or not translatable? What
about the rest?
5% are meaningful variants, but
they're not possible that one that we just looked at in the last
slide with Luke's genealogy. That's a meaningful one. Right if we
were to understand that meaning that would change a lot
of stuff.
But we know that it's not viable. It's just not possible. We understand
how that mistake had been made.
1%
Is All That Remains and those are the meaningful and
possible?
Variance but one of the things we need to understand about that 1% Now,
we're down we're not three or four hundred thousand now, we're down to three or
four thousand that's still a lot but one of
the things we need to understand about that number.
and this category
Is that while they are meaningful and possible they none
of them?
affect any Doctrine
of Christianity
Okay, they're minor in their significance.
they might be meaningful to alter the the possible meaning
of a text, but they're insignificant to
what you and I believe
Okay, so that helps us then really narrow
the number down and with that we're going
to understand how some of these mistakes are made.
So I'm going to take you you're not all now honorary members of our
community group.
Okay, and we're going to go back to the year
2017.
All the way back was that five years.
And we did a little exercise.
unbeknownst to everybody in our community group, but me I was
kind of like
a little devious in my methods, but what I
wanted people to do
was copy God's word.
Has anybody ever done that taking a chunk of God's word and
copied it?
I don't mean print it out in word. I mean just take a pen and
a paper and write it out anybody done that like a significant one
not just like Jesus wept.
We're talking about.
A book of the Bible or something like that. Well,
that was what I wanted people to do as we
were teaching through some of this stuff and we got to hell.
How scribes actually sit and write out
God's word.
I wanted people to do that for themselves. Okay, and
that's a way to grow close to the Lord.
It's one thing to read his word, but we
pay much more attention when we're reading it and reciting
it and writing it down.
Okay, because that is the methodology here the way the
monks in the Middle Ages would do it is they would actually read a
portion of the scripture.
They would meditate on it memorize it.
And then they would write it down and recite it
back as their writing it.
And then go back to the next phrase and do
it repeatedly, imagine copying the entire Bible that
way.
How long would that take right?
So that was what I just encouraged people
to do take it in your English Bible that copying
Greek manuscripts. We're just taking in your English Bible and
copy down God's word. And what we're going
to do is start out with a relatively small book Colossians.
Okay.
what I'm going to do when everybody is done,
that is I'm going to take all those manuscripts and
I'm going to
go through them like a textual critic.
Okay, and I did tell people I was going to do that.
But what is my methodology? Well, I'm going to pick one
of the manuscripts that's given to me as a base. I'm
going to go through each manuscript and compare it
to that base manuscript, and I'm going to note every
variant.
I'm going to look for spelling abbreviations addition
subtractions word orders all of this
stuff.
And I'm not going to worry so much about capitalization or punctuation because
those were not real things in the early
manuscripts.
And I'm going to tally up all of the different variants.
And then I'm going to show people how well they did as scribes.
But what I'm actually trying to do.
Is not make people feel bad.
What I'm trying to do is I'm trying to restore what it
is that they copied.
And I'm not going to look at what it is that they copied because that's
what a textual critic of the Bible actually does.
We have manuscripts, but we don't have the originals. Right? So
this is an exercise that I tried to do with
just our community group in a small setting.
Trying to mimic what text critics today are trying to
do with the New Testament.
Okay. I hadn't seen a study like this before.
But I wanted to give it a go.
and you don't need
Turns out this this case we copied the ESV. You don't
need the ESV to be able to restore the text
of the ESV.
That's the conclusion.
That we came to and I'll show you I'll walk you through it.
So now a little bit about the book of Colossians it has four chapters.
It has 95 verses it has 1582 words.
And here are our lucky participants. I took
the names off to protect the innocent or
In this case the very very guilty.
members of our community group
Okay.
We have seven manuscripts now. Some people didn't copy the ESV. And
of course, I can't use that one. Right that would be that would
be beyond the scope. But seven people copied the
ESV the entire book of Colossians. Well one person gave
up halfway through chapter one, but that's okay.
I can use that right? We have some manuscripts in
the in the historical record that aren't complete.
If it's got a chapter in it we can use it.
So I used it.
Now the results.
How many variants?
Do you think?
That we had out of seven manuscripts seven participants copying
the book of Colossians.
How many variants and I mean how many differences between
any of these manuscripts do you think that we had?
Anybody wanted to shout out a guess?
800 that's a lot.
It's a really good guess but it's that that's
a lot. We didn't quite have that many.
We had 95.
Okay, now 800 would have been really impressive that would have
made for a much better lesson, but that would have drove me nuts trying to
piece together 800 mistakes 95 though
is a lot.
Right. We have 95 verses in the book of
Colossians. That's one perverse.
If you think about it for every verse in Colossians, I
had to analyze an error.
for every verse
and then here are the results.
Of those and we had some people
were very good at this. Nobody was perfect.
Let's stop and think about that for a brief second.
nobody copied
the ESV
Colossians perfectly without making a mistake. Nobody did
it.
Some people got pretty close.
three and four
this person
who I won't tell you is me.
Had 31 and had the most mistakes.
I was not trying to make mistakes. That's the point
none of us.
Were trying to make mistakes.
Okay. So what kind of mistakes did we see? Well this
scribe f
started abbreviating cutting corners
little ampersands here for the word and Little W
slashes for the word with
okay cutting corners.
Right. Those are all variations. Those
are all variants.
Do we see abbreviations in the historical
record we do.
P46 from the second century. It's a
Greek manuscript in the red circles. You see abbreviations.
Kai Omega for Cristo
Christ
Divine names we call these nominous chakra.
In the early Church in the early manuscripts, they would
often take the Divine names and they would abbreviate him taking
the first and the last letter with a little bar on top.
To abbreviate out of reverence and respect the Divine
name. So God Jesus Christ spirit.
And there was a much bigger list too as time went on all those
abbreviations. We know exactly what was intended. They
don't come across in any translation.
But those are Corruptions.
Those were not original those were done
later. So they are variants and we
have to check those.
And we have to tally those up.
spelling mistakes
this person spelled trespasses wrong and then
spelled it right in the same verse.
Again, I won't tell you that to me.
That's a mistake. That's a variant.
scribe of f
Be filled with the knowledge of his will in Al spiritual
wisdom. They didn't spell. All right a
l l.
That's a mistake. That's a variant.
transposition deals with the word order
in Colossians 1:4 the Scribe of H says faith
in Jesus Christ.
Describe of F and all the other ones read faith in
Christ Jesus. Well Christ Jesus and
Jesus Christ are the same person.
But that's a textual corruption.
It's a mistake. It's a variant we have to tally it up.
Does it change the meeting?
No does not change the meaning do we
see this in a historical record? We absolutely do.
p46 again from the second century and 1st
Corinthians 1:1
says an apostle of Christ Jesus
Well codex cine Atticus in the
fourth Century says an apostle of Jesus Christ. It's the exact
same.
error exact same variant
That our community group unintentionally reproduced.
That is also found in the manuscripts.
Okay.
substitution
Food or drink or food and drink?
And an ore not the same word. They do mean different things
but in some context they can be synonymous.
And in this case, it can be synonymous. It's a
substitution. It's a corruption. We have to tally it.
But it does not change the meaning and only one scribe did
it the other ones were unanimous and saying food
and drink?
Now here's an interesting one.
Colossians 2:13, you might recognize this verse
and you who were raised in your trespasses.
Does that sound right?
I believe it should say you who were dead in your trespasses.
past tense before Christ
Now what kind of heretic in our community group?
Would write you who were raised in your
trespasses?
Just when I was about to call the Elders and come
to a meeting.
We thought about textual criticism and what could they possibly
other than intentionally have done to create
this heresy.
Well, it turns out if you look at the verses before
that.
Says you also were also raised with
him through faith in the powerful working of
God who raised him from the dead and you who were
raised in your trespasses.
Raised is on the brain.
Raised as a repeated word.
And our brains can often play tricks on us if
we hear of word over and over and over again, it becomes locked
and we subconsciously put it
in there when the next verb is needed.
Instead of dead, which is correct. It becomes raised.
Okay, so we can reproduce and understand this mistake.
There was no intentional heresy.
at all
omissions to the brothers at Christ
rights e c says the brothers in
Christ at colase.
Okay.
Scribe e left out the words in Christ.
Meaningful but not viable, right?
We know that all the other ones got it, right.
And brothers in Christ or just brothers has
no difference in meaning.
To us we understand.
What this mistake is is actually getting at
it's not a significant difference.
Additions, here's a little addition for all of the Saints.
And this one and all the others say for all the
saints. So just that word of.
That's all it is.
It does not affect the meaning one
bit.
I'm going to skip a few for time and we're
going to get to some of the good ones.
Actually, I do want to point this one out.
And Alternate for laga. Forlaga is the actual.
Manuscript that you're copying from. Okay. That's
the one I'm trying to reproduce in this exercise. So
scribe J.
Inscribe G read differently here.
Okay Colossians 11.
Jay says being strengthened. Gee says
may you be strengthened those are different verbal conjugations
of the of the verb to strengthen.
Okay, once a participle and one's more of a subjunctive. So
which ones correct? Well, I can't
just go to which scribe was the worst because J and G were the
two best.
Here's another instance where you do look at the proficiency
Of The Scribe and the competency Of
The Scribe these were two of the best and here they disagree.
So what's going on?
Well, it turns out that we have a bit of a moving Target.
The ESV originally said being
strengthened.
In 2016 the ESV actually changed its
wording.
To read may you be strengthened.
Okay, so a moving Target in this
case. Okay, it becomes very difficult and we do have some
snafus like this.
Which make it very difficult it adds uncertainty to
my job as a text critic when this is going on.
Now, let's talk a little bit about.
These are my favorites haploggraphy. Meaning something
is omitted.
Okay, and there's a there's a certain process of
how this happens. I'm going to read what scribes see
right here. And you tell me if this makes sense.
See to it that no one takes you captive by philosophy
and empty deceit according to human
tradition according to Christ.
See to it that no one takes you captive according to
Christ. Why would Paul write that?
Again, just one. I'm about to call the Elders.
I go through the manuals on textual criticism.
And there's a very very easy explanation to
this.
Haploggraphy often deals with
going back to reading similar words and losing
your place. Okay haploggraphy means
that you go back.
You write the first instance. Sorry you go. You look
at let me get this, right?
Okay, you write down.
the first word according
right here, which I'm circling.
You write it down. So you write down the first
occurrence of a word?
But then when you go back to the page your eye
goes back to the second occurrence of
the word.
and everything between the first and the second occurrence is
then
Is then omitted?
Okay, so everything in the verse that's
underlined here described just omitted.
Okay, his eyes went back to a different
spot on the page.
Which was incorrect and all those words got left out.
Look, here's the word according. He wrote down according,
but when he went back to the page, he looked
at this word according.
And all the words that are underlined were emitted.
Okay, that's haploggraphy. That's when you go back to a similar word
or a similar ending to a word.
And leave out the stuff in between. Does that happen
in the manuscripts?
It does.
Codex alexandrinus of the fifth century
and First Corinthians 9:2 describe left
out the entire verse.
He omitted all of
nine verse 2
why because the last four words of verse 1
and the last four of words of verse 2 are
the exactly the same.
so the Scribe
went back to the place. He thought was the
right place, but it was not he went back to the other four
words and ended up omitting all of verse 2.
Okay, the Scribe e says sexual
immorality passion evil desire. We're listing all
these sins, but they left out impurity.
Why because it has the same ending as
the word right before it the ity.
And is so easy to go back and see
something similar and lose your place. Okay
the brain.
Sometimes plays tricks on us.
Here's another good one.
If with Christ you died to the elemental spirits of
the world, do you submit to regulations?
That's not even a real sentence.
What's missing what's missing is the
part of why as if you were still alive in
the world, do you submit to regulations?
How did this error come about the exact same way? You're right
down this word world?
And your eye goes back to this word world.
And you leave out everything in between all of
these omittances of either a word and
ending of a word or an entire sentence or entire verse.
Are easily explained?
By understanding how the mind works.
And by seeing this repeated over and over again in
the manuscripts. Now, the opposite of haploggraphy is
datography. That's where
we have a repetition so
Listen to this.
Continue steadfastly in prayer being watchful in
it with Thanksgiving at the same time pray also for us that
God may open to us that God may open to us a
door for the world.
to catch that
how did this happen?
the word us
So just like the last instance was you see the
first occurrence and your mind goes back to the second and you
leave out stuff here you write the first and the second
and then your eye goes back to the first again.
and you rewrite the entire passage in between
okay, one of our scribes and our community group.
Did this without even knowing?
Does this happen in the manuscripts?
Yes, it does.
Codex vaticanus are the fourth Century
in Acts. 1934 says great is Artemis of
the Ephesians great is Artemis of the
Ephesians.
Why because the endings of the words before and after that?
Are exactly the same and they've repeated.
the words
now we tally up all of
these variants.
I told you there was 95.
How do we then?
Critique this and come to conclusions. Well,
we got to give these confidence ranges.
Okay. This is what the Committees do the actual text
critics of the New Testament. They will assign all
of these variences.
That we see in all the manuscripts different levels of confidence
and I've kind of mimicked that here if we give it
an a that means we're 100% confident in the reading.
B 75 C50 d25
Okay in the confidence ranges of whether these are
could be legitimate or not.
Here's what came up with.
All but two of them.
Were a hundred percent?
Because they were easily identified we
understood that they were not viable. These mistakes
could be could be explained by.
Just our knowledge of how the mind works.
two of them were a little difficult because the
scribes were
You know, it just wasn't one. It was two who made
the variant and sometimes the two one
of the two.
Were pretty competent in what else
they had done so it becomes a little bit more difficult.
And so I had to give a couple of these a little bit lower confidence.
But here's what the end result is.
Out of 95 variants where we have a
variant of one per verse.
in the book of Colossians
The confidence in restoring the original ESV
without even looking at it.
From Seven manuscripts none of which were perfect.
All of which had errors in
them was 99.97.
That's not bad.
when you factor in
that if we would have gone back to these two.
And said, well the majority of the manuscripts had this one.
So I'm going to actually choose that to be the original and the
majority of this had this one to be original and
if I would have chosen the majority rules out
of those it would have been a hundred percent.
We would have reconstructed perfectly.
the ESV
from
all imperfect manuscripts
Okay. I hope that provides some encouragement.
because when we take this
To the data that we have. We have
5,800 manuscripts of the New Testament
in Greek. Not seven 5,800
Plus all of the other languages plus all of the church fathers, so
what that's going to do for us.
it will provide confidence but
We will also have a lot more than 95 variants,
right? The reason why we had 95 in
our community group was because we had seven think how much
more we would have had if our community group would
have had 5,800 people.
Doing this and none of those would have been perfect either.
Okay. I hope you can see how the number of mistakes and variances just
going to escalate.
from there
Now we have 15 minutes left. Actually. This will
work out pretty good.
Remember in week one.
I told you to open your Bibles to acts 8:37
and remember that.
And only a few of you had that verse in
it. Most of your Bibles didn't have that verse.
Okay acts 8:37 is one of the more famous examples
of a verse that many people would say is
missing in your Bible.
The King James has acts 8:37 the
modern translations like your ESV and IV.
Those do not have that verse so now
we're actually going to walk through a little
bit of textual criticism.
Of our verse so this is no longer an exercise
in English. Now, we're going to actually see what the deal
is.
With acts 8:37. Does it
belong in our Bibles or not? Some Bibles have
it some don't who got it, right?
And how do we know?
Because it's one thing for us to read it in our
Bible. See it's missing and just go. Yeah.
Okay, the footnote down here says it's not in
some manuscripts that's good enough for me.
Well, that wasn't good enough for me ever.
I wanted to pursue that understand why is
it not in some manuscripts? Because we are talking
about the word of God here.
So let's go through it. Let's look at the data you all can
read that.
Can't read that but I will tell you what it what it
says.
This is our database for acts 8:37.
Okay, and in the
white columns so out here and
down.
And when I say down we are starting with the first
century second third fourth all
the way down to 15 16
17th centuries. Okay. So time is
running down the page.
So all of these
numbers and letters in these white columns
represent the database that we have all of
the witnesses for the New Testament text.
that do not have
acts 8:37 in them.
Okay, that's in the white.
We have here gray a light
gray right here. These are all
of the manuscript Witnesses the Greek and
other languages and church fathers.
witnesses that do have the verse
but not the way that Erasmus and the
King James have the verse.
It's a slightly different text.
And this darker gray out here.
are all the witnesses that do
have
acts 8:37
in the correct wording of the King James.
One of the first things that we notice and you
don't have to read the numbers to know all of these numbers that
are squished together right here in the later centuries.
Those are which kind of text.
Byzantine those are Byzantine manuscripts the
Byzantine textual tradition the mass
of manuscripts in the Middle Ages.
those usually
agree with the Texas receptus
and then therefore the King James.
but in this case
they don't.
All of those Mass manuscripts in the Middle Ages do not have
acts 8:37 in it.
There are a fair amount of manuscripts that do.
Have acts 8:37.
Okay, but we're going to get into that.
Now is acts 8:37 and important
verse. Well read what it says. Then Philip said
this is Ethiopian eunuch. And Philip is evangelizing.
He wants to get baptized in verse 837 says
then Philip says if you believe
with all your heart you may
And he answered and said, I believe that Jesus Christ
is the Son of God. Well, at least it's nothing
important, right?
Now this is very important.
It's a testimony of his faith.
That allows him to get baptized.
Why would somebody omit that right and that's
what we hear a lot. Your Bible doesn't have that in there. It's
it's not correct or worse it's satanic.
Okay, we've heard that.
Let's look at the evidence. We're text critics. Now. Let's actually
do textual criticism. Let's look at the data. The earliest
that we see of Acts
8:37 is from the church father
irenaeus irenaeus if you've heard
of that name before maybe you have
But you might not know where he's from. He's from Leon in
France.
Okay, that's where his church was.
in modern day, France
he writes.
As did also the believing unit himself and
immediately requesting to be baptized. He said I believe Jesus
Christ to be the Son of God. Well, it sounds a lot like our
verse right?
right
that was taken from about the year 180.
very old
that's early church.
but
where is irenaeus?
He's all the way out in the westernmost
part of the church.
We talked about the Western text as being one
that
It it paraphrases it commentates it
it adds it Smooths.
It brings tradition into the text to
bring out the meaning.
Irenaeus is in the western part of Europe.
The very first Greek manuscript that we have that
contains the verse is codex e which
is in a sixth century.
Okay, and this is also a western manuscript?
So why did Erasmus put it in his text?
If the manuscript evidence wasn't there, why did he
do it? Let's look into his methodology here. So he had
a manuscript.
Of the Greek of the book of Acts and it
had the verse but the
verse is located here in this red box.
It's not in the main body.
It's in the margin.
Okay, and this is a manuscript from the 15th century,
so it's not old.
Remember Erasmus is living in the 16th century. So
this is within a hundred years of Erasmus here.
It's not old.
Okay, but this was his evidence that he had
to work with because he did not have remember. He did not have 5,800
manuscripts.
He used seven.
So here's his methodology in his first edition of 1516 Erasmus
claims that the verse quote is not
found in the Greek manuscripts.
he's familiar with it, but it is not found in the Greek manuscripts,
but
because it is in his Latin version which
again remember Latin is mostly
over here in the western part.
of Europe
right
and because in his manuscript in
the Greek that he did have it's in the margin.
He comes to this conclusion that however, I think the emission
was the result of a negligent scribe.
Whether he knew it or not or would admit to it or
not. He is doing textual criticism. He is making a judgment.
Of whether that verse should be in the Bible or not.
And he made the Judgment that it should why because he
had Witnesses. He had the Latin which
has it in and he had this Greek manuscript which
was on the side. Well, maybe the Scribe just
like omitted it accidentally and
let somebody later or put it on the side and it actually was a mistake
and it should be long in the text. That was his
conclusion.
The problem or one of the other problems is he did not
include that Greek text it was on the margin what
he did was he took the Latin because he thought that was
better in this verse and back translated
it into Greek.
That opens up a whole other.
Set of possible errors.
So by doing that he wrote down a Greek text
for acts 8:37, which has never been found
in any.
manuscript
ever
except one that was in the 17th
century or the late 16th century, which was
after Erasmus had lived.
So that doesn't count.
But it's this text.
that Erasmus chooses from the back translated
Latin
Which gets?
solidified into the textus receptus
which then gets translated into the King James
Bible.
But that text has never been found in any manuscript.
So is this verse missing?
Does your Bible that does not include that?
Have an error. Did they take it out? Is it purposeful?
Here's the logic flow. Here's the workflow. What we
know is acts 8:37 was unjustifiably added
by Erasmus in 1516.
He made a textual criticism judgment call.
That was not supported.
He thought it was a mistake, but he had no proof of that.
Now the verse designation.
remember
were originated by stefanus in his
Greek text in 1551.
Okay, that's after Erasmus now they
get verses.
Added to it.
The King James is translated from a Greek
addition that contained erasmus's text of the
verse.
and stefanus's first designation 37
in it
So the King James then has an ax 837.
But when textural criticism is later applied and
found that diverse is not
original.
It was a later Western addition in the
western part of the church in the early part of the church, but it
was in addition nonetheless when that was discovered.
When you correctly remove the verse.
number 37 goes away
because you can't Cascade back, right? You're not going to
you're not gonna take away the tradition of verse 8:30 or
38 is Now 37 39 is now 38. You're
not going to do that.
It's much more simpler.
To just omit the entire verse.
And so that's what your version your ESV or your
NIV or whatever other Modern English Bible
that you use has done.
They have applied that textual criticism methodology found
that the verse was not original by
doing that research.
Have omitted it and then verse 37.
goes away
So this is the official decision of the committee. I'm
not going to read that. It's
it's
it's complex, but it does go through a lot of
good data, but what I would suggest is
You have Bibles you have commentaries you have these other things if
you're at all interested in what we
talked about tonight.
I would strongly encourage you to get a textural.
commentary
Okay textual commentary we'll go
through exactly what we just did with acts 837 but
for every verse.
That has these variants.
And go through and explain the textual
criticism and how you arrive at the decision.
of whether
it's variant A or B or C or D or whatever. Okay.
So a textural commentary will do
that. Here's just one example of one up here. This is Philip Comfort.
It's it's actually
pretty well written it's exhaustive and
he will tell you which Modern English
versions have chosen variant A or B or C
or D. And so it's it's fairly
easily to digest.
Okay, but in our last minute.
We want to address this critical question.
Is our new testament reliable, we just found out
that there's 300 to 400,000 variants.
There's verses that are in one Bible, but not
another Bible.
And I will tell you.
That people have used everything that
I just said.
As an attack on the word of
God.
as an argument for you and I
to lose our trust in the Bible and what
it says.
Okay, but let's walk through we've already walked through the science
part of this and how you know, we don't don't take these emotional
arguments and lose our faith.
We just go no, let's sit down. Let's actually
look at this rationally and let's just
see.
Who's right?
Okay, we learned in our first week.
That God's word is inspired in the
original writings without error in their meeting in their
meeting. Well now we're looking at copies ever since
then we're looking at copies and there's no guarantee that
those copies are inerrant.
or perfect
I just showed you how seven Born Again Believers in our
community group can try their best to copy God's word
and never get it, right.
How much more when we have 5800 manuscripts and
all these other languages as well?
But it is true. We do not have the
original manuscripts and there are hundreds of thousands of
variations in the copies.
but
this is because we have an abundance of manuscripts.
Okay, and we've talked about the number.
And human beings were the ones who were
making the copies.
And human beings are not known for being perfect.
Now let's address the variations and summarize this.
99% are untranslatable.
insignificant
or they're just not possibly original.
Remember I said the goal of textual criticism is to understand the
origination of an error if we
can understand the origination of an error we can rightly call
it an error.
And it becomes not even possible to be
an original.
writing
only 1% are significant impossible, but
No, Christian doctrine is affected.
In any way whatsoever.
In that 1%
so therefore
we have a very high confidence.
A very high confidence in reconstructing the original New
Testament.
even in spite of those difficulties
Okay. I hope this has been informative. This has
been something that's not often taught. I love it. I
will be up here. If you want to talk about any additional questions,
you might have I'm hoping you
do have questions, but at the most are the least
I hope this has been comforting because people
will talk about this.
When they're attacking the faith.
Okay, I've heard it. I've seen it. I've watched YouTube. I've watched
the videos. It's out there.
But we have ways to deal with this. This is not
something that we just get up in arms and we panic and
we run and you know hide we can
face this and this is something that
has been proven now over the last few centuries. So
this is nothing new.
At all, so at the very least I hope you understand and take
the the takeaways from this slide and I hope
it's a blessing and I hope it's a comfort and an encouragement.
to you all but if you have other questions, I
will be happy to
answer them. So thank you guys so much for coming out. I
appreciate it.